[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of ask dr. Mike this time all the
questions are coming from you so I'm
really excited to answer all of your
questions let's get to it had a question
I just recently got my wisdom teeth
taken out and I have four huge holes in
my mouth how can I get them to close as
quick as possible getting your wisdom
teeth taken out is definitely a painful
experience I had all four of mine taken
out and they were all impacted it really
did hurt so I feel you there is no
secret way to speed up the healing
process the best thing that you can do
is prevent infection by keeping the area
clean really what's the number one thing
that you shouldn't do is smoke smoking
does prolong healing time and that's the
number one thing that we talk to our
patients during surgeries is that they
should stop smoking as soon as possible
so I just find out that I am gluten
intolerant
can you explain what is gluten
intolerance why it can happen and what
is the effect to my body if I still
consume gluten can I eat like 1 2 3 4 or
5 small but for a treat for myself is it
dangers thank you to my Bella goon
intolerance is a very popular subject
right now but the way that I like to
break it down to my patients is that
there's two types of gluten issues one
is celiac disease you've heard about it
in the news and celiac disease is actual
damage in your intestines from eating
gluten which is a protein byproduct of
wheat in celiac disease when you consume
wheat your body has an autoimmune
response which means that your own body
attacks its own cells because of an
overreaction to the wheat product and
you get physical damage in your
intestines now the second part of this
is something called non celiac wheat
sensitivity there's people that are
sensitive to wheat but not necessarily
to the gluten component in non celiac
wheat sensitivity we don't have the
research to back up what happens if you
continue eating wheat however my opinion
you should not eat wheat because it's
gonna make you feel better you'll be in
less of a fog you'll have less diarrhea
less bloating so if you do have symptoms
from eating wheat just don't eat it
okay that's a great question fires and
it really does give strength to the
statement that you can die of too much
of anything so yes you can die of taking
too much water because you limit your
body's ability to properly manage the
electrolytes within your system
electrolytes are crucial for managing
everyday life functions like making your
brain work your heart work or even your
kidneys thanks hey girls if you do have
IBS and it's true treatment depends on
which type of IBS you have there's IBS
that's mostly diarrhea predominant
there's IBS constipation predominant and
there's also a mixed version as well for
mild disease or symptoms you can do some
dietary modifications there's a specific
diet that we put patients on who suffer
from IBS called a fodmap diet what that
diet does is it excludes certain foods
that your body is unable to digest and
the bacteria in your stomach are able to
digest so it causes that uncomfortable
bloating feeling pain and it really does
mess with your bowel movements if you're
able to eliminate those types of foods
people do see an improvement in their
symptoms if you do have a moderate or
severe form of the illness there are
medications that you can use to treat
your illness however in order to get
those medications and to find out what
medications are suited best for your
symptoms it's important to go see your
doctor hi dr. Mike my question for you
is how can I improve my eczema because
none of the products that my
dermatologists have recommended towards
me or pretty much anything that I've
been attempting to doing hasn't really
worked out well what can I do myself
like involving nutrition or stuff that I
can kind of control that it's not super
financially expensive eczema is a very
tricky illness and I understand your
frustration if you've already seen a
dermatologist they probably discuss some
of the treatment options with you
talking about UV light therapy steroid
creams maybe even medications that
affect your immune system but like you
said those are expensive modifications
expensive treatments some of them do
come with side effects links between
eczema flares and diet has been a
popular subject that's been up for
debate it's not clear what the link is
but we certainly know that a link does
exist
I don't like recommending to my patients
eliminating certain foods from their
diets but this is a great time to have a
conversation with your dermatologist or
your primary care doctor to get tested
for food allergies because there is a
relationship and those who had food
allergies to those who have worsening
eczema if you're able to find out early
on that you have a food allergy and
you're able to eliminate that specific
food from your diet it's possible that
your eczema flares will decrease or at
least that when they do happen they
won't be as bad
hey dr. Mike my question for you is how
and when did you know which area of
medicine you wanted to specialize in I
chose family medicine specifically
because I love continuity of care I love
being able to communicate with my
patients every single day and also I
love not limiting myself to focusing on
one specific body part or organ I think
the beauty of family medicine lies in
that I'm able to see the effect my
treatment has on my patient I'm able to
see how it improves their lives and
that's incredibly rewarding hi dr. Mike
I'm involved in a lot of sporting
activities and I kind of sprained my
ankles when I play sport I was wondering
if there's anything that I can do to
help strengthen my ankles like an
exercise that way I won't hurt them as
much as I do
hey Anna the way that you prevent ankle
injuries is through improving your
proprioception which is your body's
ability to know where your limbs are at
all times even without seeing them the
best way to strengthen your ankle
prevent injury is to do proprioception
exercises the first one that I want all
my patients to try is to stand on one
foot of course without a sneaker with
their hands to their sides eyes open and
see how long they can hold that position
then to make the exercise a little
harder you can take your arms and put
them at your sides which will make it
the balancing a little bit more
difficult and then the next part very
challenging is to do the same thing with
your arms at your sides but close your
eyes and see how long you can hold that
position the longer you can hold that
position the less likely you are to have
an
injury you can certainly see your
physical therapists who will teach you
more advanced exercises and work with
you directly to prevent future injuries
I see over and over again people
claiming that vitamin D is to cure all
for all illnesses and clearly it's not
the case there's been a huge uproar and
uptick in studies and articles coming
out recently saying that Americans are
taking too much vitamin D now I've said
this maybe two months ago in a YouTube
video called our vitamins fake news
check out that video and see the real
deal on vitamin D I would like it if you
could explain to people why asthma has
many different levels why some people
fall in one puppet an inhaler will help
them and other people with severe asthma
like myself need nebulizer is an oxygen
therapy because I feel a lot of people
still take asthma as a bit of a joke and
they seem to think that people with
asthma are hypochondriacs of things I've
spent many times in ICU
I've been critically ill of her pleurisy
I've had many things and I've been told
by friends you know if you're gonna be
making that noise can you go home
because you're annoying me up in a nasty
box be quiet so if you could maybe
feature this and answer the question
that would be amazing and oh really
appreciate it because I feel like I'm
talking to a brick wall when I try to
explain to people coming from a doctor
it might be better thanks Mike first of
all to all those who said asthma is a
joke they are completely wrong they
don't know what they're talking about
I'm so sorry you had to go through that
asthma is a very serious illness and
I've had to intubate otherwise healthy
16 year olds with illness there are
levels to asthma you have mild asthma
moderate asthma and severe asthma
there's further classifications but
that's for your doctor to worry about
and the difference between the levels of
asthma is the difference between the
types of medications you need to take so
for the more severe asthma you're gonna
need to take control or medications once
to prevent asthma attacks from happening
in the first place versus for mild
intermittent asthma you can just have a
rescue inhaler and use it as needed
you clearly have a more advanced case of
asthma so you do need to be on a
controller medication and I'm so sorry
you have to go through all of this
ridicule from your friends because they
don't know what they're talking about
alright guys it's time
for the lightning round what is the
healthiest way to burn fat
hey high-intensity interval training
it's where you build muscle and burn fat
at the same time how can I get fatter
really though well you could sleep less
than six hours a day eat a ton of carbs
and be a huge couch potato how to deal
with insomnia insomnia is tricky because
you need to get a full history and a
full physical exam and sometimes get
some lab work done not an easy question
to answer go see your doctor if you
weren't a doctor what other career would
you have pursued detective I loved
investigating and that's frankly what I
do every day as a doctor how do you
remove eye bags eye bags make me not
confident Thanks I bags can be removed
with a cold spoon or fillers I've seen
some great results what type of doctor
are you family medicine the best
specialty out there what's the most
challenging part of being a doctor
constantly refreshing your knowledge
things change every single day and it's
important that you stay up-to-date
I really enjoyed answering all of your
questions today I wasn't able to get to
all the questions and if you still have
something that you're itching to learn
about leave a comment down below I'll
make sure to get to it and I hope you're
excited for the next installment of ask
doctor might leave a comment down below
I'll be sure to get to it why did I
highlight be sure it doesn't make any
sense and it's really one of those
diagnosed diseases yeah that's a
mouthful I
[Music]